jesse waters has studied this particular
fdc report he's the author of the
fantastic book
how i saved the world and we are
grateful to have him join us tonight to
unravel the mystery of eric well well
jesse waters thank you
thank you who is this guy well he likes
the finer things in life and like most
liberals he wants someone else
to pay for it he must have developed
this appetite for far east cuisine
when he was dating fang fang but he
loves the 90 dollar
sushi roll at oku sushi in washington
d.c
that comes with truffle soy caviar and
gold flakes
also likes to frequent because he's a
working man the charlie palmer
steakhouse where he can get a 130
steak and that is not included with a
side or a
soup or a salad everything is a la carte
he knows that
and of course you have to stay at your
wife's ritz carlton in half moon bay
tucker
i mean you can't go back to your meager
house in your district
you got to wake up the next morning and
get 18 holes in
at the course that overlooks the pacific
then you can go back to have lunch that
someone else
of course is paying for but this is why
people hate politicians
it's because these narcissist finger
waggers
go into politics just for the
comfortable lifestyle
that they would never be able to achieve
or afford
in any other profession because they
don't have the brains or the talent
so it's the napa valley cabs the
limousines the international junkets
corporate lobbyists and donors all pay
for it and we pay for the rest the
taxpayers
and he goes on tv the next day and says
we got to get big money
out of politics and everything is
corrupt that's probably the biggest lie
he's told and
there's been a lot of them i gotta ask i
mean you never really get the
perspective
of the servants now we have this picture
on the screen there there's
a man that swallow refers to as his
native bearer his coulee
his servant of color and he's grinning
he's obviously
under some pressure to pretend that he
adores eric swell because
swalwell is in charge of course he's the
great white hunter
but why shouldn't we subpoena that man
that unheard voice and let him tell his
story
what is it like to have eric swalwell as
your
as your chief as your commander i just
i just feel bad for the camel because
swalwell does not have good manners as
we've seen on a few tv clips
in cable but if he is really a champion
of women's rights did he go over to
cutter and ask
why it's legal to beat your wife there
as someone that says the world's going
to end in 12 years did he ask qatar
about their emissions
as the as the pro-working democrat that
he claims to be
did he ask about how slave labor is
building the soccer stadium over there
i i have a feeling this was not a fact
finding
mission tucker and maybe when i say fact
probably daiquiris was the only thing he
was looking for
i and that you know i was thinking
tequila sunrises but you're absolutely
right daiquiris or froze and i just want
to put
a call out to our viewers if you know
his native bearer
his apparently adoring servant that we
put up in that picture if you've got his
number send it to us
because we would like to hear from him
we think that all voices should be heard
especially yours jesse waters thank you
so much for that insight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else